ما اعتقد انه اقرب بلد او كثيرون يعتقدون
ان اقرب بلد يمكن ان يلعب دور الوسيط في
هذه الازمه الاوكرانيه هو النمسا بالنظر
الى ان العديد من الروس جزء من مجتمعها
وهو مثال ابرز على الجزء الغربي من العالم
الذي له علاقات وثيقه مع روسيا هل يمكن ان
نرى النمسا تلعب دور الوسيط في هذه الازمه
الاوكرانيه الروسيه
بحاجه الى طرفين الى مستعداني للحوار
والان لا ارى اوكرانيا ولا روسيا مستعده
للحوار خاصه
غدا ان كان يا سحبه قواتها وعدم القيام
باي شيء
انا
بامكانيه
ولكن هدفنا يجب ان يكون اعاده تاسيس
السلام في اوكرانيا
مستقبلها ما الذي يمكن ان يوقف هذه الحرب
الاجابه سهله جدا اييي رئيس امريكا الحرب
غدا
لاحترامي النزاهه وسيادته الاراضي
الاوكرانيه